in haiti it appears death is never too
far away
saturday's devastating earthquake has
pushed the demand for coffins
and if that weren't enough haitians are
now preparing for another potential
disaster
tropical storm grace is set to make
landfall
bringing with it the risk of flash
floods landslides and further
complicating efforts to find survivors
we are bracing for tropical storm grace
that is coming so we have to have a
contingency so we can address the people
that are
that out of fear stay out of their
houses and sleep out on the streets
the magnitude 7.2 earthquake has added
to the list of crises haitians had been
dealing with
from gang violence that has affected
every aspect of life for many to last
month's assassination of president
jovenel muis and of course the covet 19
pandemic
here in colombia an all-out effort is
underway as regional nations send
desperately needed aid
the scale and damage becomes clear from
above
but this is the scene on the ground
stretcher beds and mattresses sprawled
among the rubble under the shade of
trees
the lack of medical resources is clear
with thousands in need of care doctors
are left to treat patients outside
hospital wards are overwhelmed with
health care workers struggling to cope
haiti's prime minister flew to the
seafront town of likai in the nation's
southwest an area which had been worst
affected by the quake
when i arrived in the south of the
country we saw the destruction many
houses are destroyed rescue teams are
working to find victims and survivors in
the rubble one thing i noticed was the
dignity of the people despite the
situation they are affected but
resilient they fight to survive
[Music]
on the streets of lakhai locals line up
to feed their families but this is far
from business as usual
football fields sprawled with survivors
forced to shelter with the few
belongings they have left
since the earthquake i didn't feel well
we're on the football field our home is
destroyed we can't drink the water and
many people are staying here
many here are still traumatized by the
2010 earthquake that killed hundreds of
thousands of people near the capital
port-au-prince
for many the only safe place to sleep
for now is on the streets
but the looming tropical storm brings
with it more risks leaving haitians
feeling hopeless with no place to go
wondering when things will get better
jillian wolf al jazeera